repasamos los titulares de la prensa
internacional con rosa pérez más de
euros a bienvenida a feliz martes para
ti muy buen día como nos vamos a empezar
hablando de la cob 26 con the economist
buenos días raúl exacto hemos querido ya
preparar un poco la antesala de la que
se considera como la cumbre por el clima
más importante desde la de parís de 2015
así es rosa y como titula economics las
promesas rotas la escasez de energía y
el coi 19 van a obstaculizar está con 26
rosa exacto este artículo no se hallan a
un poquito el terreno para entender lo
que se puede alcanzar en términos de
acuerdos y de lucha contra el cambio
climático en esta copa que se iba a
celebrar en glasgow y por un lado
recuerda que cada cinco años se acordó
en la cumbre de parís se debería no
revisar los compromisos y la
implementación de la ssa de políticas
para frenar el cambio climático y
recordemos que una de las cosas que se
acordó en la capital francesa fue
intentar limitar el aumento de la
temperatura global por debajo de los dos
grados celsius respecto de la época
industrial e idealmente limitar este
aumento de la temperatura al 15 grados
sin embargo como recuerdo recientemente
la agencia internacional de la energía
hay solamente un 5 por ciento de
posibilidades de que se llegue a cumplir
este compromiso y recordemos que entre
otras cosas tal y como señala este
artículo pues por un lado está el hecho
de que los países ricos no están
cumpliendo con sus promesas en términos
de financiación de la transición
ecológica a los países pobres que por
otro lado como pues también nos señala
este titular y pues desarrolla el texto
que el escenario de escasez energético
que bueno que se da a día de hoy pues no
es digamos favorable a estas discusiones
ya dejar de lado ciertos recursos
naturales contaminantes y por otro lado
señala también que si bien para muchos
países ricos donde el índice de
vacunación ha permitido que se deje de
ya de un lado la preocupación por la
pandemia pues hay muchos países pobres
donde todavía sigue siendo pues él uno
de los mayores asuntos en nacionales a
los que hacer frente
lo que esto va a agravar todavía más las
desigualdades en términos de
representatividad en esta cumbre de
glasgow una crisis energía de más rosa
que hablamos precisamente ayer en
nuestro tema del día pues dejamos el
cambio climático a un lado por ahora y
vamos a seguir hablando de facebook que
sigue dando de qué hablar no rosa
empezamos con the atlantic la historia
no nos juzgará
amablemente este es un artículo que hizo
a drink la fans este artículo
exactamente recoge ciertas
conversaciones
entre empleados y directivos de facebook
no y pues en relación a todo lo que está
saliendo la luz las nuevas revelaciones
sobre pues a lo que se sabía y las
alertas internas que había dentro de la
compañía sobre cómo se estaba
organizando este asalto al capitolio
pues ahí pues comunicaciones a las que
ha tenido acceso este medio en que pues
trabajadores de la compañía señalaban a
sus directivos a lo que tenían que hacer
algo para frenar esta expansión de la
desinformación en términos del supuesto
fraude electoral sin pruebas
donald trump y pues por ejemplo hay una
unas frases cuando ocurrió el asalto al
capitolio mark zuckerberg envió un
comunicado a todos sus trabajadores
diciendo esto son momentos difíciles
entiendo que estén tristes y está este
mensaje distintos trabajadores
respondieron no estamos tristes estamos
enfadados esto es nuestra culpa y
después la historia no nos va a juzgar
de forma amable y que pues sale este
titular y ya parece que tomaron cartas
en el asunto rosa porque precisamente
facebook le eliminó un vídeo al
presidente en su cuenta ya el presidente
brasil diario bolsonaro donde decía
donde relacionaba la vacuna del coi 19
con implicaciones con el sida pues rosas
seguimos con el new york times tras las
revelaciones de la informante de
facebook lleva a la compañía la campaña
a europa esta campaña se traslada europa
el artículo de the addams a tratar ya no
y myaaisha exacto porque francisco que
no está informante está ahora haciendo
un tour por europa que empezó ayer en el
parlamento británico en el que quiere
recoger apoyos para legislar no
irregular esto sea de gigantes
tecnológicos como es facebook
señala en este artículo que o'hagen
defendió la misma tesis que ha venido
revelando y defendiendo desde hace
semanas de que facebook no va a cambiar
su modelo de negocio mientras le
continuó funcionando y que por lo tanto
tiene que haber una intervención
política aquí y recordemos que
precisamente esta intervención de joven
en el parlamento británico ocurrió al
mismo tiempo que salieron nuevas
revelaciones sobre también el papel de
facebook en la expansión de la
desinformación en india por ejemplo y al
tiempo que facebook ayer también
anunciaba sus beneficios en términos
económicos en este último trimestre
vamos ahora a hablar del wall street
journal en el mismo tema rosa mira con
el wall street journal raúl lo que hemos
querido mostrar es que recordemos que
este medio también estadounidense está a
la base no de toda esta problemática y
esta discusión internacional acerca del
poder de facebook porque francisco again
empezó a filtrar los documentos al wall
street journal precisamente y de aquí
salió toda la investigación de los
papeles de facebook y simplemente
queríamos comentar que encontramos en la
página web de este medio un suv con
todas las cuestiones que se han abierto
a raíz de estas revelaciones y con el
siguiente tema rosa no dejamos a un lado
las redes sociales y le importaría mucho
a la gente que se la pasa haciendo
selfish como a mí por ejemplo vamos al
país de américa los self inmortales bajo
la lupa de los epidemiólogos el artículo
es de oriol way este es un artículo que
abre precisamente el país américa la
edición americana de este medio porque
bueno es sorprendente que según un
estudio de la funda de la fundación y os
que trata enfermedades del viajero pues
se señala que las series mortales son ya
un tema de salud pública que en este en
lo que llevamos de 2021 ha muerto una
persona por semana pues en accidentes
relacionados con el hecho de tomarse un
autorretrato y pues sobre todo estos
accidentes tienen lugar entre
adolescentes y jóvenes al momento de
fotografiarse en lugares altos no sobre
todo pues son caídas desde las alturas
como por ejemplo tal y como señala este
artículo desde las catas del niágara y
pues una política que ha surgido en
respuesta a este tipo de accidentes es
que por ejemplo en la india tal y como
nos señala este texto del país ya se han
declarado ciertas zonas libres the
selfish pues rosa muchísimas gracias ojo
entonces pilas con as el fish peligrosas
muchísimas gracias nueva mañana con más
titulares de la prensa vamos ahora a
darle paso a nuestro primer invitado al
día